[Musique]
doivent heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 les invités
voici le sommaire
nous recevons ce soir jean claude husson
le maire de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
nous ferons un point sur la première de
la gauche à quatre jours du premier tour
nous avons rencontré la semaine dernière
la mère de laterrière nelly duthu lors
de ses premiers voeux dans la salle de
spectacle du scarabée
l'occasion de faire un point sur l'année
écoulée et puis nous finirons avec
l'interview du boxeur élan pour toi
double champion de france marvin petit
qui affrontera samedi l'espanyol 0 b
santana pour le titre de champion de
l'union européenne des poids légers ont
début de cette émission avec jean claude
husson maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines à quatre jours
du premier tour de la primaire de la
gauche
nous allons faire un point avec vous
bonsoir ben ça alors on va débuter avec
l'actualité
hier manuel valls s'est pris une gifle
une malheureuse gifle on peut le dire
moi j'ai une question où on laisse de
côté la gifle est ce que vous pensez pas
là qu'il ya vraiment une désaffection
des gens par rapport au ps
oui il y en a une c'est à nous de
convaincre les électeurs
mais je dirais que la démocratie c'est
pas là c'est pas la violence ceux qui
veulent participer la démocratie je les
encourage à rejoindre les partis
politiques à rejoindre les associations
à rejoindre les syndicats on attend en
france toutes les structures pour
pouvoir s'exprimer participer au débat
qui est très bien alors le premier tour
c'est dans quatre jours comment ça va se
dérouler devant les événements dans les
yvelines qui aura 120 bureaux de vote
chaque bureau est présidé par une
personne qui était d
il y a une équipe dans chaque bureau les
bureaux ouvrent de 9h à 19h chaque
citoyens qui souhaitent participer à ces
élections peut bien sûr voter je
souhaite tout de suite avant que je
n'oublie préciser un point très
important pour les électeurs
en tout cas ceux qui se sont inscrits
sur les listes électorales en 2016 parce
que là les listes 2016 elles viennent de
ce terme de se clore dans les communes
via les commissions électorales en
janvier donc on les a pas donc les
électeurs ceux qui sont inscrits sur les
listes électorales en 2016 doivent venir
avec une attestation d'inscription sur
les listes électorales c'est un point
très important qui est qu on a peu
entendu jusqu'à présent et il ya le cas
des jeunes électeurs ceux qui ont eu 18
ans en 2016 eux sont inscrits
automatiquement sur la liste électorale
mais comme ils sont pas sur nos listes
d'élections pour dimanche
ils devront venir avec une attestation
de domicile et une pièce d'identité
comme tous les électeurs donc d'être mis
en moi c'est noté merci dites moi vous
avez vu la primaire de la droite et du
centre
oui tu as un véritable succès on parlait
de désinfection par rapport au ps vous
attendez à peu près le même
nombre de participants en 2011 vous en
aviez au niveau national 2 millions 500
mille
voilà donc on espère on espère faire
mieux on verra mais le but c'est de
lancer la dynamique c'est vrai que
c'était un peu compliqué à gauche avec
la tante du président qui a finalement
de ne se représente pas donc ça un peu
qu'elles ont rendu difficile le
lancement de la mécanique mais ça y est
ça fasse ça va se faire et on a quelques
mois d'abord choisir le candidat de
plusieurs partis politiques
il n'y a pas que le parti socialiste il
ya le front démocrate de jean luc
bennahmias il ya union des démocrates
écologique de françois de rugy il ya le
parti radical de gauche de sylvia pinel
ils participent tous à ces élections il
n'y a pas que le parti socialiste est
tous ces partis le soir du 29
soutiendront le candidat qui sera choisi
par les yeux et pourtant le secrétaire
du parti jean-christophe cambadélis a
quand même un peu peur il parle lui de 1
million 500 mille voire 2 millions il
sent que le vent est en train de tourner
quand même pour le parti socialiste
et vous vous y croyez toujours une bonne
question d'y croire ou ne pas y croire
c'est il faut y aller et convaincre les
électeurs
voilà et après on verra ce qu'ils
allaient france et le
le choix démocratique vous avez vu des
premiers débats qui se sont déroulés
oui le référé de vincenti c'était plutôt
que c'était assez tiède qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous on a dit la même
chose sur les primaires de la droite 1
le premier semblait un petit peu contre
un on dirait ça s'est réveillé sur le
deuxième et puis sur le troisième on
s'en vont on est bien que les gens
jettent les candidats jettent leurs
dernières cartes donc il est possible
que ce que la même chose pour le
troisième débat de jeudi mais pourtant à
l'issue de ces deux débats il y en a un
qui a touché votre coeur on peut dire ça
comme ça
oui alors moi je suis très organiser des
colonnes des lignes par thème
j'avance petit à petit effectivement
j'ai choisi à l'issue du deuxième débat
le candidat que je soutiens qui est
benoît hamon voilà j'avais le choix
entre benoît hamon et vincent peillon
j'hésitais entre les deux j'ai choisi
benoît hamon je l'a annoncé lundi matin
sur mon blog est donc pour vous c'est sa
ligne peut aujourd'hui rassembler tous
les électeurs elle peut rassembler mais
ce qui est important pour moi c'est la
notion de redistribution vers les
français c'est ce qu'à mon avis les
français attendent et je pense que c'est
le programme qui est le plus apte à
assurer ce point il dit par distribution
il est plein de choses mais au final
pour moi c'est celui qui assurera en
termes de programme la redistribution
vers les français c'est ce qui est à mon
avis attendu selon des dernières études
c'est une pop sortira en janvier les
ouvriers et les fonctionnaires
maintenant vote pour le fn ou pour les
républicains il n'y a pas un souci
c'était quand même le socle du ps en
plus il ya monsieur macron qui selon
tous les sondages et devant le prochain
vainqueur de la primaire de la gauche
vous vous êtes toujours confiants ou
comme certains peuvent le dire en fait
cette primaire c'est un peu la rochelle
avant l'heure les universités d'été
juste pour trouver une ligne pour la
science je reste sur le même point la
redistribution ça n'a pas pu n'a pas été
fait lors du quinquennat c'est la
déception pour un certain nombre de
français et notamment des électeurs de
la gauche et c'est pour ça que certains
regardent ailleurs
et donc il faut il faut revenir à cette
ligne directrice qui est importante
aujourd'hui on peut pas avoir des
familles des gens qui travaillent et ont
du mal à vivre du mal à se loger
même à se nourrir à éduquer leurs
enfants enfin ce sont les bases des
valeurs de la gauche et donc il va
falloir y revenir et bien je vous
remercie monsieur son et puis à bonn
primaires de la gauche
merci beaucoup on poursuit cette
émission avec de la politique vendredi
13 janvier à la verrière la maire
communiste présenté ses premiers voeux
dans la salle de spectacle du scarabée
des voeux qu'elle a voulu porter sur
l'espoir et sur la lutte en faveur du
projet de la zac gare bécane
j'ai plein de projets pour 2010 cinq
principes clairs
on a fait une petite piste là mais le
projet de crèche pour une maison de
santé
et puis faire aboutir gardez kansas ont
des projets quand même qu'ils sont plus
que motivant et la sacd a regardé cannes
depuis un an est bloqué la réalisation
est bloqué depuis plus d'un an
on a le maire d'elancourt qui bloque
vraiment le projet
on a pourtant le soutien de monsieur
laugier le scan madame rosetti le
soutien de me surveiller le soutien de
la ministre du logement
enfin on a tous les soutiens possibles
imaginables
tout le monde nous dit que le projet est
viable que le territoire en a besoin
pour son expansion que nous la ville on
en a besoin pour respirer
le nombre de logements créés fait partie
intégrante de du projet de territoire et
du nombre de logements globale sur le
territoire c'est-à-dire compte on ne
remplit pas le prohon ne
remplit pas les objectifs si la zac gare
beckham ne serait pas ré voilà c'était
parti des incompréhensions et sur le
territoire de la verrière
on a beaucoup de veyrier roi qui
souhaitent rester sur la verrière
mais avec une
un choix de logements en plus important
aujourd'hui à quatre cents 400 demandes
de logement sur la dernière pendant
comment satisfaire parce qu'on n'a plus
de logement
c'est aussi une façon de
permettre aux verriers roi et à notre
bien sûr de se loger et de devenir aussi
propriétaire j'étais dans les deux cas
les deux possibilités
voilà les verrières ont ils sont
attachés au soir il faut qu'on sorte de
ça pour pour l'intérêt des derniers rois
et pour l'intérêt du territoire
aussi ne semble pas comprendre ça sera
peut-être l'un des combats les plus
importants de sa carrière samedi le
boxeur double champion de france marvin
petit va affronter l'espanyol 0 b
santana au palais des sports de
levallois perret est en jeu la ceinture
de l'union européenne des poids légers
à quelques jours du combat et bien le
boxeur est déjà prêt je suis avec marvin
petit kit originaire d'el en cours il
est en train de préparer en ce moment
son combat pour le titre de la ceinture
européenne des poids légers
il va affronter un espagnol santana à
levallois dans quelques jours alors
marvin comment vous sentez vous à
l'approché ce combat là personnellement
je suis je me sens je me sens bien c'est
on va dire c'est même la première fois
je me sens aussi bien que ça j'ai fait
une bonne préparation avec bob site a
donc là je pense que ce combat je vais
j'ai ramené ses ceintures et déjà en
plus à la base c'est chez nous le combat
vers la ceinture va rester en france
donc
santana c'est un gros morceau il a
remporté 14 victoires en 14 combats
disputés
vous avez une seule défaite dans votre
carrière en pro voilà que le match
s'annonce équilibré en tout cas explosif
oui ça va être un des jeux ce jeu steam
auquel aucun adversaire et ça va être un
gros combat
c'est un très très bon boxeur c'est un
style 10 donc je pense que moi pas là je
vais faire mon taf que comme un conte a
établi avec tanguy moi dans ma tête je
suis prêt maintenant je suis pressé
d'être au rendez vous le 21 et comment
avez-vous axé votre préparation ça a été
plus dur peut-être que d'habitude pour
ce combat qui sera peut-être le combat
de votre vie on peut le dire oui on va
dire c'est le combat qui va m'apporter
beaucoup dans ma carrière parce que
la faux pas je laisse passer cette
ceinture ces rediffusions direction
qu'elle n'est plus déjà et c'est une
ceinture de l'union européenne que je
peux pas lui donner c'est pas possible
j'ai très très belle non je pourrai pas
lui donner même qu'il est invaincu je
vais lui mettre une défaite face à tout
le monde
le monde passe par là et moi je me
rappelle qu'entre yvan mendy j'avais
quatorze combats 14 victoires et voilà
c'est pas pour ça qu'il m'a pas battu
donc après maintenant je maintenant je
me suis peut paraître dur dur dur
mentalement je suis prêt physiquement
donc maintenant j'attends j'attends le
rendez vous le 21 et au niveau
d'entraînement justement vous êtes
préparés comment il ya eu de la course
ait eu des mises de gants il ya eu quoi
en fait pour beaucoup dans votre
préparation
en fait c'est mon préparateur physique
bauxite à un très très bon préparateur
ça je dis j'ai fait une préparation
spéciale
je me suis préparé sur plusieurs trucs
différents tous les jours c'était avec
un on va dire au tapis on a fait des
fonctionnaires au tapis on a fait des
fractionnés endurance musculaire on a
fait des fonctionnaires ça qu'on a fait
des mises de gants technique on a fait
des palettes
on a fait pas mal de trucs vous être
français physiquement ou tactiquement
peut-être sur ces derniers mois je me
suis renforcé fait physiquement et
tactiquement aussi sur vos cds des deux
côtés et même du physique là je suis
encore mieux que me qu'avant et santana
vous le connaissez parfaitement ou pas
du tout c'est un peu l'inconnu pour vous
je connais pas du tout on risque notre
sol ring le 21 et j'espère qu'il est
bien prêt parce que moi je suis prêt
est-ce que vous avez déjà mis en place
une tactique spécifique pour remporter
le combat ait anguille farruggia votre
coach oui on a mis une tactique
spécifique c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait on
sait comme les box il vas y vas beaucoup
il va beaucoup on bat avec son bras il
sombra avec sandra avant ça david de
bras donc après on va falloir bien
monter les mains d accès que comme il
faut avancer mettre des coups vous allez
y allez directement vous voulez que le
combat se termine très rapidement vous
allez faire peut-être un peu dur et pour
le fatiguer déjà je veux lui montrer que
c'est moi le patron solo ring dès le
premier round je veux des jolies falloir
que c'est moi le patron et et que je
suis chez moi en france et qu'il n'a
rien à faire ici en france à vouloir
contre la ceinture et le fait que ce
soit levallois en france ça va jouer
dans votre tête
ça va jouer beaucoup parce que c'est pas
possible tu repars et que cette ceinture
chez lui en espagne
je ne veux pas lui laisser c'est bien
falloir qu'il me met ko eux même si je
t'emm je me levais je vais je suis
jusqu'à temps je que je reste par terre
qu'on voit que c'est fini vous compter
sur le soutien du public
je sais que vous êtes très apprécié
notamment en france vous avez de
nombreux supporters à travers l'hexagone
est ce que vous comptez sur nos
supporters pour remporter la victoire
oui je consens et supportera aussi parce
que yara et j'ai beaucoup de fans qui
vont venir j'ai des fans de la
communauté gitane même dans la
communauté or gitane hélas il n'a pas vu
y'a pas mal de fans donc je pense que
tout ce soutien et mon est là et
j'espère beaucoup qui vont être là ce
jour là donc après voilà moi non moi je
vais penser déjà à faire mon travail que
dans ma tête là je suis je suis prêt à
faire mon travail et est ce que le
danger n'est pas là justement de
s'enflammer peut-être un peu trop vite
dans ce combat avec la foule avec le
public l'entousiasme je vais pas penser
à la foulée au public je restais
concentré dans mon travail et je vais
écouter l'entraîneur de mon entraîneur
de ski va mettre en place et je vais
boxer comme comme il faut quoi il y à la
caméra juste devant vous justement vous
ici est-ce que vous pouvez adresser un
message à votre adversaire santana si
nous regarde en ce moment sur tf6 78
mais j'espère qu'il va préparer santana
parce que je te garantis je tiens
vraiment vraiment du mal et il y aura in
hôpital pas très loin avec beaucoup de
pansements ci s'est assuré turix le
message est passé
marvin le jeu en rappel le combat est
programmé ce sens
10 21 janvier à levallois merci de nous
avoir suivis bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]